a trento
abbiamo un problema ve lo dico subito
che è quello che io sento dire da tanti
studenti da tanti colleghi non si può
più fare impresa perché perché le
tecnologie sostituiscono il lavoro e le
banche non ti danno il capitale tra i
tanti mestieri che faccio ci arrivo del
venture capital e quindi un po di
capitale di solito solamente io ma prima
di metterci il mio di capitale
chiedo ai futuri imprenditori ma scusami
ma perché il capitale e il lavoro non lo
prendi dai tuoi clienti
quindi stasera parliamo di farlo in
customers assumere i clienti clienti che
i miei colleghi del dipartimento di
marketing vogliono sempre celebrare
dicendo metteteli al centro dei vostri
progetti è il centro mettiamo lì sotto
facciamoli lavorare
una volta buona questi clienti e questo
il senso e per guarda che non era solo
un'idea mia mi faccio capire che 150
anni fa qualcuno ci aveva già pensato e
non sorprendetevi se un bocconiano città
carlo marx cosa diceva carlo massa
onestamente anche un sacco di
stupidaggini però due cose 22 cose devo
dire un'alleanza e cate la prima cosa
era cosa molto semplice diceva che i
mezzi di produzione devono appartenere
al popolo
ora se gli frugate in tasca ciascuno di
noi almeno uno dei più grandi mezzi di
produzione della storia produzione
dell'informazione produzione dei mezzi
di pagamento abbiamo visto prima i black
bloc chain
immaginate di avere in tasca uno dei più
grandi mezzi di produzione al mondo bene
quando il capitalismo perde il controllo
sui mezzi di produzione perché finiscono
al popolo capite che diventa un problema
usare il capitale la seconda cosa diceva
marx era lavoratori di tutto il mondo
unitevi
lui aveva in mente il partito comunista
perché io molto più semplicemente
ovviamente twitter linkedin che sono
meccanismi di coordinamento del popolo
esattamente e pensate che un personaggio
come ma zac
dal mio punto di vista è un imprenditore
marxista perché che cos'è facebook non
ha più grande azienda di media al mondo
senza aver mai assunto un giornalista
senza aver mai comprato un edicola
che cos'è d'altra parte whatsapp
sono più grandi di telecomunicazioni al
mondo senza una torre o un call center
che cos'è huber se non la più grande
azienda di logistica senza automobili e
senza dipendenti
cos'è airbnb che usa pensate il vostro
capitale la vostra casa è il vostro
lavoro la vostra ospitalità per
diventare la più grande azienda di
ospitalità al mondo quindi quattro
aziende
potrei dire marxiste nel senso che hanno
utilizzato l'intelligenza distribuita
per fare a meno nel capitale era meno
del lavoro questo è se volete un
principio che sta prendendo piede e che
quindi in un certo senso toglie la
grande scusa del a non troviamo il
capitale dai fornitori tradizionali le
banche e non abbiamo più il lavoro
perché le macchine lo sostituiscono
quindi il principio molto semplice
provate ad assumere il vostro cliente
nuovo cast questo un po il messaggio la
serata
niente di nuovo se ci pensate non so chi
di voi ha mai visto quella chiave a
brugola strumento di masochismo
meccanico una delle esperienze più
allucinanti pensa alla nostra vita nei
week end
ogni tanto mia moglie dice perché non
andiamo a fare un giro all'ikea io noi
li estivo che micro economicamente a un
esperimento marxista perché per che
schiavizza i clienti andata così con
semplici istruzioni per altro a vedere
chi ha non a testi perché giustamente
non avendo tempo e voglia di tradurli ci
ha sostanzialmente illustrato il
meccanismo di lavoro volontario e le
paghiamo per lavorare pensate un po e il
disegno fondamentale di chi è questo il
prodotto è incompleto senza il
contributo il capitale e il lavoro dei
clienti che mi da ridire ci metti la
macchina e portapacchi civati anche i
soldi poi vai a casa
e passi weekend a montare la libreria
billy questo è il principio per cui ikea
e antesignana dei vari facebook e
linkedin ma è di fatto un modello dal
mio punto di vista molto intelligente
visto che sono invero a digitare i
filosofi marxisti non poteva mancare
antonio gramsci il quale
grande uomo grande intellettuale scrisse
dal carcere per altro è perché all'epoca
c'erano i fascisti all'epoca oggi
figuriamoci e mettevano in galera gli
intellettuali lui scrisse questa bella
biografia che era sostanzialmente
l'intellettuale organico e disse io odio
gli indifferenti odio chi non parteggia
lo credo
aveva lasciato rifluire in carcere
perché gramsci ha ragione e ci dice
ancora oggi che il cliente deve essere
come il suo intellettuale organico che
vuol dire non vuol dire che senza
pesticidi e vuol dire che lo coltiviamo
dentro la nostra organizzazione questo
il concetto di organico e se ci pensate
questo è il senso di una azienda come
tripadvisor tripadvisor cos'è la nemesi
della guida michelin una volta dovevamo
assumere degli esperti indipendenti che
dovevano andare in tutti i vari settori
della ristorazione dell'ospitalità e
dare dei giudizi oggettivi oggi ciascuno
di noi partecipate in questo senso
tripadvisor odia gli indifferenti
partecipa alla produzione di questa
consapevolezza collettiva ciascuno di
noi è membro di un'organizzazione
distribuita che produce che cosa un
capitale sociale fondamentale un bene
pubblico fondamentale che la fiducia il
trust d'altra parte noi tutti oggi su
questo genere di un modello produttivo
ci mettiamo le mani anzi più
correttamente le mani ce la mettiamo
dell'ikea su tripadvisor noi mettiamo le
dita se ci pensate
ma lo facciamo anche su facebook non
mettiamo il pollice se siamo contenti
highlight non pensate sul link
dimettiamo l'indice no addirittura
facciamo le connessioni su tripadvisor a
monitor
a volte capita che mettiamo diciamo il
pollice el'indice non fosse medio
esattamente perché esprimiamo dissenso e
ci sta e guarda che dissenso elemento
fondamentale
pensate che oggi per fondare un partito
minimo minimo di servono 5 stelle no ea
volte appunto serve pollice l'indice e
in certi casi il medio
la verità è che le aziende cercano
l'anulare cioè cercano il contratto di
fedeltà e fiducia questo è un po la
sfida fondamentale perché alla fine è
sempre il cliente che ci mette il
capitale e il lavoro
d'altra parte oggi voi tutti
anche solo per andare in pizzeria una
sera ormai consultate non più la guida
michelin
ma quel prodotto di capitale
esperienziale collettivo e di lavoro
collettivo che appunto tripadvisor come
dicevo prima fare impresa è difficile e
se pensate che oggi anche un kebabbaro
albanese oggi si vuole aprire un kebab a
trento minimo minimo deve avere quattro
palle quattro partner di peraltro una
volta ne bastavano un paio di palle no
adesso minimo 45 se volete proprio avere
successo
questo però presuppone che anche modello
organizzativo del fare impresa cambiano
cambia e il premio nobel di qualche
giorni fa l'economia che a riccio fair
che professioni chicago ha vinto perché
9 poi perché ha capito che non sono più
le gerarchie i modelli organizzativi
antichi ma sono le spinte gentili sono
sistemi di incentivi che convincono in
maniera intelligente morbida i clienti a
fare quello che volete voi
sostanzialmente quindi dati orienti
migliaia di ricercare dice mi raccomando
dai una leggera spinta da spingere
spingere devi creare un sistema di
incentivi corretti a questo punto il
cliente partecipo al tuo gioco
organizzativo perché perché gli stai
dando accesso alle informazioni e
internet questo fatto ma gli stai dando
anche gli strumenti di partecipare alla
tua sfida organizzativa e questo è
quello che succede
il libretto di lavoro e la tessera del
sindacato collassano collassano del
nostro telefonino nel mezzo di
produzione che appartiene al popolo
se pensate questi due fenomeni la
tessera sindacale cioè il contratto che
difende gli interessi del popolo del
lavoratore ormai è diventato appunto un
meccanismo collettivo è il software
rating che ci difende molto più delle
associazioni di consumatori tradizionali
noi siamo in grado ormai come clienti di
svergognare un'azienda sui social molto
prima che intervenga l'antitrust o il
tribunale per condannarle oggi peraltro
noi stipuliamo un contratto di lavoro di
collaborazione
se pensate a voi tutti con rosa google
maps noi forniamo al posto del
cantoniere tradizionale o della polizia
informazioni sul traffico puntuali
precise volontarie e che producono un
bene pubblico
questo è molto importante perché ha
proprio cambiato anche se volete la
scala di maslov di questi ultimi tempi
vi ricordate la scala di maslov in alto
ha bisogno di appartenenza di identità
poi al centro ai bisogni organizzativi e
in basso
hai bisogno di base nutrimento cibo
caldo freddo non dico l'altra cosa ma ci
siamo intesi i miei studenti non sono
più così ve lo dico sinceramente cioè io
posso chiudere il 48 ore in aula senza
cibo senza acqua e non è che facciano
troppo casino ma se gli tolgo il wifi e
la batteria ragazzi questi ministro fa
scopare la soluzione veramente no ed è
quello che succede oggi in questo
modello qua ormai siamo tenuti a
partecipare a questi processi sociali
d'altra parte vi dicevo oltre al lavoro
ormai il cliente dell'importante
capitale esattamente no non lo devo
aiutare le banche prima il collega ha
detto che i found non esiste soltanto il
computer degli altri è vero la banca non
esiste solo il capitale degli altri che
cosa ci dicono questi due moderni
filosofi ora 150 anni ed a cui do e
l'altro un moderno filosofo leggermente
figlio di buona donna però diciamo anche
noi particolarmente noi a trevor cane
che il fondatore di google prodon diceva
150 linea che la proprietà è un furto
io più modestamente do ragione a canali
che dice allora che è un furto è
semplicemente un metodo molto
inefficiente di allocare gli asset e le
risorse produttive e devo dire che ha
ragione kahlan e che il quale
sostanzialmente si è inventato un metodo
per allocare le risorse produttive
distribuite sul territorio convincendo
in maniera diciamo gentile no con gene
di cui parlava tailer e qualche volta
meno gentile ma diciamo teoricamente
dire certamente lo ha fatto airbnb chi
di voi
cinque anni fa avrebbe preso un aereo
sarebbe partito per il wyoming per
andare in una fattoria sperduta in mezzo
ai bufali e in braccio a sconosciuti
nessuno è peccato che con l'arrivo di
armi
voi tutti fate esattamente questo
semplicemente perché il capitale e il
lavoro sono stati forniti da questa rete
sociale quindi il passaggio a questo
punto sul capitale proprio questo quello
che ci dice che il chiedo scusa che il
nuovo capitale sono i dati
pensate a questa grande forma di
socialismo digitale che scatterà l'anno
prossimo questo e lenin che ci indica
quando c'erano proprio prossimo l'unione
europea fa due cose straordinarie e vi
invito a riflettere
la prima si chiama gdp ora è la seconda
si chiama pst to sono due direttive che
fanno che cosa espropriano le aziende le
banche e le istituzioni della proprietà
del dato e restituiscono la proprietà
del dato a ciascuno di noi quindi non
c'è più nessuna scusa per non fare
impresa perché dall'anno prossimo unione
europea che ha tanti difetti ma qualche
volta la zecca espropria i titolari
della proprietà del data del loro
diritto di proprietà gli lascia il
possesso la custodia ma affida a
chiunque abbia la capacità di convincere
il cliente di affidargli quel compito il
potere di ottenere quel dato e sfidare
le grandi organizzazioni quindi è una
grandissima opportunità con il 2018 una
grande rivoluzione veramente è la
finestra di un socialismo digitale molto
interessante anche per un liberale
quindi chiudo dicendo il principio del
fare impresa cambia profondamente siamo
cresciuti noi stessi abbiamo insegnato
ai nostri studenti un modello di impresa
molto calligrafico non può come piero
della francesca che introdusse la
prospettiva rifaceva il matematico
perché non si può allenava abbastanza si
mise a dipingere dipingendo interpretò
esattamente il senso della matematica
cioè rigore formalismo è un po come i
nostri business plan tutto pianificato
tutto rigoroso prospettiva centrale
tutti guardano nella stessa direzione
ma quel mondo ordinato e preciso rischia
di finire in effetti qualche centinaia
d'anni dopo è arrivato un grandissimo
genio proprio picasso quindi se piero ha
messo ordine pablo ha messo un grande
disordine organizzato pablo picasso
aveva tecnica sopraffina lui diceva ci
ho messo vent'anni per imparare a
disegnare come raffaello ci metterò il
resto della vita
per imparare a disegnare come un bambino
bene la sua capacità di se volete
semplificare ed introdurre nella logica
del cubismo la legittimazione di diverse
prospettive lui e inventore del cubismo
oggi l'economia dei dati è un grande e
iper cubo una grande e legittima
prospettiva diversa e questo è il suo
quadro secondo me più famoso leda mosel
davinio che sta al moma di new york no
le signorine d'avignone non mi fate dire
il contesto in cui questa questo quadro
è stato dipinto perché penso che sia
intuitivo ma che cos'è questo quadro
questo quadro è la legittimazione
strutturale della diversa prospettiva
questo quadro come il cubismo legittima
le prospettive di lato di sopra di sotto
tutte sono accettate tutte sono
scomposte e sintetizzate è il concetto
che stiamo utilizzando il capitale
estetico e il lavoro percettivo del
cliente popolo di gas cela vendicata la
via cento anni fa di attribuire la
legittimazione organizzativa estetica
agli occhi del cliente quindi chiudo
dicendo questo è torno sul se volete in
italia nella più bella scultura che
scova può rappresentare la chiusura di
questo tedecsa è la mission che vi
lascio cioè quella di diventare un
ibrido diventare una contaminazione di
diventare un po cyborg un filino
bastardi se posso dire inteso come
sintesi di uomo e macchina questa
scultura bellissima di umberto boccioni
sta al museo del novecento a milano ed è
secondo me la perfetta rappresentazione
di questo equilibrio del nostro tempo
una sintesi di via vuoti ed i pieni di
uomo e di macchina di chiari e di scuri
è un disegno è un progetto bellissimo è
un progetto che come dicevo prima non
richiede poi così tanti capitali perché
alla fine
bastano 20 centesimi per ricordarsi di
questa bella storia
io non so quindi se siete leone o
gazzella
ma vi chiedo di cominciare a correre
grazie grazie